well thank you to the organizers thank
you all for coming to the first talk in
the morning and so I will talk a little
bit more about what Anna talked about
already according to interactive
communication okay so i will just in the
beginning quickly go over over the model
again and if at any point of time the
questions just ask you know we can
always cut off material in the end
doesn't matter it's more important that
everybody understands roughly what's
going on okay so what if our interactive
communication is basically error
correction for conversations so a claim
we know very well how to do error
correction for one-way communication so
let's play the gare cracking codes right
so that's a classical setting we have
two parties Alice and Bob Ellis has some
information let's say n symbols n bits
and it wants to send it to Bob ok well
Alice sends them to Bob but now these
noise right so what if of the n symbols
at Alice sends some constant fraction of
these symbols get corrupted any fracture
any Delta let's say I don't know ten
percent twenty percent of these symbols
get corrupted well now Bob obviously
doesn't know what I wanted to send him
so what can we do well we just makes a
transmission a little bit longer right
so what do we do instead of sending n
symbols LS sends alpha times n symbols
for our some constant alpha and now if
you do this in the correct way if you
use error correcting codes so no matter
where these ten percent of errors happen
Bob will always know exactly what's the
outcome in the noiseless settings turns
out to be pretty useful now most
communications aren't just one way most
communication well you something you
respond I respond to that be fun to find
in a research project we want to find a
lunch place at I'm day to meet you know
most of these information go back and
forth so now we want to have such a
conversation in a noisy room well what's
model basically give two parties Alice
and Bob and we have a conversation in
mind so Ellis has some some information
bob has some information
bf's is protocol which Alice sends some
symbol over Zimbabwe spawns Ellis and
some symbol Bob response and so on and
so forth and symbols and you can always
make these symbols you know binary
everything we can express in binary and
you can also assume that basically more
or less without of loss of generality in
here said we go alternating right so if
i want to send 10 things but I send one
saying I let you say something you just
say nothing sent me a zero i sent the
next thing and so on so we just go
alternating so I've an end simple
conversation now what happens if there's
noise some Delta ten percent get corrupt
the big question is can we make the
conversation slightly longer instead of
sending going back and forth n times can
we go back and forth alpha n times for
some constant alpha for some constant
size alphabet and still achieve and
basically at the end no matter where
these ten percent of errors happen we
wanted both parties know exactly what's
the outcome in the noiseless setting
would it be ok so a priori it's not
clear that this is even possible just
using error correcting codes doesn't
work just like unab told us last time
basically just wanting one message being
completely corrupted which is a very
very small error fraction it's like 1
over n error faction will destroy the
whole protocol but what we've seen last
time is that there are indeed protocols
which achieve something non trivial so
what are the important parameters that
we are looking for here I mean what are
the important parameters for error
correcting codes well one thing is the
rate if I give you a certain error
fraction I want to know by how much do I
have to blow up my conversation and
ideally we want at least concentrate we
may be one doll so a good constant here
but but let's fun for today we stick for
just any constant you know all the
informations erased I'm sorry and
tomorrow we will actually talk about
what the consonants and how we get
something reasonable
here for now we're just happy with any
constant so what is this is just one of
the two blowup in length and also if you
use a large alphabets and you know log
of the alphabet size see as I saying
that's really important about error
correcting codes is computational
efficiency right I mean Shannon showed
City exist error correcting codes with
Scott properties that's a really cool
mathematical statement but it's not
really practically useful if decoding
and encoding takes exponential time
nobody uses random codes horrible right
i mean says they're not they're not
useful so what we've also want we want
something that's computationally
efficient in decoding and encoding and
then the next question we can ask maybe
what's maximum amount of areas that we
tolerate if you talk about why it kind
of up to what error rate can be at least
get some constant constant rate if you
don't if you at least don't know exactly
how the trade-off between error rate and
and andreas communication radius maybe
we can at least determine what's maximum
amount of noise that we can tolerate
okay so in the interactive setting so in
the error-correcting setting we know
what does this we get you know almost
linear time decoding and coding error
correcting codes this this optimal rate
distance trade-offs more or less and we
can tolerate errors up to I guess one
half if we go over large off of it how
does this work for interactive coating
Sherman showed set for some error rate
small for any error it's more than one
over 240 we can achieve constant rate
using three codes which unfortunately we
don't know how to construct or decode so
exponential time but still great result
right and then so we haven't seen this
but what you have seen yesterday is
actually if we use also three coats but
it's like the better protocol we can get
an Eric tolerate any error rate of 14
that's below one force that's what I'm
shoulders this constant it
and two other prior works that are
important so all of these things are not
efficient as improve not be efficient or
you don't know how to make some
efficient it's a randomized construction
that probably gives a tree good it's the
decoding process and we also don't have
some things that so even it's both yeah
so so things even even if he has is this
conjectured explicit record right which
I'm talker talked about very briefly
yesterday even if we had even if he
knows that this conjecture is true even
if we know that this three code exists
and we can kind of compute each thing
efficiently we would still get
exponential time here because of
decoding and encoding but Sherman also
has this like convolution based
probabilistic constructionism foremost
choices isn't there including is
efficient yeah the decoding is still
exponential term um yeah absolutely in
classic and in one way you could be
there was the heavy approach and the
shell yeah so we talked only about
hemming right now version where you're
suing you know yeah so I means it's
random errors are obviously easy as and
send adversary errors if you have it for
adversarial errors you can get it for in
them so there are certain things that
people looked into it before yeah so
people have I'm not going I stick I want
to stick this kind of one model yeah i
mean this but basically everything is
more or less subsumed by is what we know
for the address of our case and once you
know it forever serial case you know
what you get for Z Burnham case for for
random heirs once you can talk tolerate
constant adversarial areas you can be
ski boot setup to tolerate much higher
random air so I think for random Ellen
there's children already
torre era fraction of 11 minus yeah
anything that's branded away from one
half rate for the constants I love
alphabet you can reach one half friend I
mean basically if you have random errors
you can just repeat every symbol 10
times right if you have an error rate of
one half minus epsilon now it's an error
rates that's really bonded away from
from the air it gets much smaller and
then you build a protocol on top of this
right they'll hurt your rate but it will
still stay a constant know for randomly
no efficient construction and 4 4
episode we do know some official
constructions so in particular brodsky
kalai showed that as a randomized
algorithm that the Chiefs as it runs in
n square time it can tolerate any error
rate smaller than one over 16 and has
constant rate so then by just doing a
repetition code on top of said you can
also tolerate any venom error rates it
spawned away from half although this
constant rate so do we know a
deterministic polynomial time
construction yeah so deterministic is is
harder yes so that's when I see open
questions something else this also use
of strikeouts yes but only on small
small chunks I mean we will see
something similar to this later all
right and then we can also get a linear
time like n pulley locked i'm iffy if
you're willing to suffer amor in Z in
the error rates that we can tolerate
okay so that's basically that's the
state of the art or I mean that was the
state of the art and now we can ask
basically two questions just looking it
is one question is well one over four
right that's the best that we that sets
the best sets on the board is that's
best possible it's one of the phone
yesterday made a really good case it you
know one over four should be is a
natural limit that's so that's one
question it's 10 for the best optimize
the optimal error rates that we can't
operate as the other question is well I
want to show you actually how do we
achieve these efficient protocols
and ideally what we also would want is
how can we achieve efficiency and
maximal errors at the same time okay so
that's going to be basically as a whole
talk today and it's mostly based on
joint work this most Afari and Medusa
done ok questions up to this point
what's model yes see our model where the
air is measured over both adversary and
see that's why you get the woods what if
you kind of say well the max carer for a
is this the next care for B is this you
get a better you get different bonds and
clem will say something about
essentially this model on Thursday yeah
other questions okay cool so let's start
to say this is 1 over 4 question is one
of four the best said we can tolerate or
is there something better okay so I know
yesterday said well so he was his he is
the argument that yeah someone over for
tomorrow mark so what we know is that
for every protocol pi success success
protocol pi prime which is similar in in
rate is a very much a similar in and the
number of rounds that it uses which
simulates
I against anything that's less in one
part right one quarter minus epsilon and
and on the other hand the claim was said
if you look even at a very simple
protocol in particular for I equals
exchange I will say in a second what
that is so it does not exist by prime
simulating I against delta equals 14
okay so what does exchange experiences
release the simplest interactive
protocols that you can think of Alice
gets a bit Bob gets a bit and they just
want to know each other spit I just want
to send each other each bit now the
claim is that even this this that's the
simplest protocol they at least both
parties need to send some things the
simplest thing that's not just one way
right even the simple protocol the claim
is we cannot simulate with anything
that's smaller with against an error
rates that's four or one more okay and
proof was essentially well one party
talks less and half of the time so less
than half of thick ends the number of
total round severe should be running so
we can corrupt
half of its transmission
and well that killed any anything that
you can do right we can interpolate
between whether you want to send a one
anyone to send a zero and that's it so
case closed maybe there's somebody see
what might be at least questionable
about this proof exactly right so yes
one party will talk less than half of
the time but how does the adversary know
in advance which parties is right well
so one way to go about this is to say
well let's restrict ourselves to
protocols in which both parties declare
in advance who is talking at what time
if you have such protocols send this
proof costume right if we declare up
front who's talking at what time I can
easily look who's talking less was
talking more and and then we could so
yes that that we didn't write this proof
in our paper we first assume that that
that we made the assumption that you
were talking about and then we're at the
proof we like we assume that it was
known ahead of time which party would
would would speak in each round and then
we wrote this group yeah yeah no I'm not
saying that you tweet I am NOT saying
that he tweets model to make the proof
work if that's what it's like there was
a bug in our no proof no there's no back
in the proof right no no no no no no no
I mean see I mean the only thing that it
needs is you know it holds for it holds
for exactly the model there we declare
in advance who talks and at what time
right yeah so and that's the standard
model right i mean that's models that
everybody looked at so the standard
model and so i want to call these things
non-adaptive right because in advance
i'm declaring who talks at what time are
not adapting to ours
so let's let's talk about these models
so we've non-adaptive and obviously if
you have non-adaptive protocols also
there's going to be some adaptive
protocols and as I'm said non-adaptive
was or is C standard model in which all
of these questions first studied right
non-adaptive just means non-adaptive
means we have a fixed communication
order and each round the aissur aissur
Alice listens and Bob speaks or Bob
speaks and Alice lessons and then
whoever listens receives what is spoken
except when the adversary interferes and
that won't happen 12 right that's a
standard model and and this is a
perfectly perfectly good proof for
exactly the standard model right so if
we say it does not exist a non-adaptive
i prime which simulates it against one
force ok um right but then still maybe
we can come up with a model that is it
up and I claim in reality protocol
people communications are adaptive all
right so let's let's look at how what
does this little bounce a right
supposedly about the rules of the game
that if the adversary flips the coin and
decides who is guessing with who they
will speak more than half of the time so
he has fifty percent chance of
succeeding in his task at that
considered acceptable oh that's exactly
oh this except the point of view of the
sea well he can't corrupt it a hundred
percent of the time no no no I mean if
you want we want basically that you were
if your friend of Mines protocols or
randomized adversary we want to be right
at least this one minus something
negligible probability then what's the
problem with why the way let's think
about it I'm gonna tell you well it's
not truly oh the videos and learn what
it versus choice was as a protocol runs
okay players can learn information about
Oh exactly let's think about it all
right so here's I mean you can just
basically flip each each pit with
probability half right that's one way to
to ruin this whole thing of one player
you focus on one player and you flip
half with its bit in the beginning you
flip a coin which play focus on and then
for each bit you flip a coin whether you
corrupted or not so it makes this
transmission completely useless and you
only spend on average kind of one over
for sale right that that's that the same
right and this is exactly kind of what
works for this proof right but now let's
think about it how this would work out
in reality all right you pick up the
phone you call your mom right and you
say something to her the line is
perfectly clear you'll line is perfectly
clear because the address that I decided
to pick on your mom right your mom is
going to say something yeah it does
virtue for for good reason so the
adversary pics on your mom right so
whatever your mom says fifty percent of
that gets corrupted so you can hear it
is you can hear this noise you but not
mistake it for something that's actually
eligible right but you can't understand
what's it actually sing okay so now it's
your turn again you say something right
so I'm watch out you're being that right
so fifty percent gets corrupted which
means that we have really no clue what
was that but you know is that some
errors happened right so we respond back
and everything is perfectly clear Ellis
does somebody have a mom named else that
would be so cool
okay again right says I'm saying fifty
percent of the things are corrupted it's
my turn again I say something comes
through and this goes on for infinity
that's not what would happen right
because if my line is perfectly clear
but my mom's line is totally blocked out
just white noise why am I talking I've
nothing to say I can t Marissa I haven't
understand a single thing of what she's
saying right so naturally what would
happen is i would talk less and i would
let my mom talk more which anyway
happens all the time right but
independent of errors but exactly so
once i start pulling back and my mom
talks more the adversary could not null
out fifty percent of what she's talking
because now he's spending more than a
quarter of the whole conversation so
eventually he needs to spend less than
fifty percent in this point i will
understand what she's saying and we can
continue with our conversation right so
this says at least maybe there's a hope
that we can beat one quarter okay and
yeah so let me spoil it yes we can and
we can shows it as the amount of error
said we can tolerate to over seven quick
calculation tourism betters as better
than 1 over 4 that's good the surprising
thing is to of sevens tight okay and in
the beginning is that sounds very
surprising but if i had a few more
minutes i don't want to spend too much
time on this i'm sure i could actually
convince you the two by seven is the
right bound and it's a very natural pond
okay we can do this offline anybody
who's interested i will try to give a
little bit of a hint why this is the
case
people can speak of the same time made
it so let's make this form right so I
just made some claims but I haven't
specified a model I haven't you know I
haven't said anything form so let me
just write down what exactly and meaning
so yeah let's first define adaptive
protocols and so what so here each
player gets to choose each party in each
round can choose whether to listen or
speak independently based on the history
based on randomness if they want to
whatever and now we need to consider
multiple cases right easiest case if we
have listened or speak or speak and
listen you just do the same thing right
whoever listens receives for the other
person talks unless the adversary
decides to interfere that can happen too
often alright so this case is pretty
clear if both parties speak well it's
easy what we do nothing right both
parties speak nobody listens perfect so
it's nothing to specify right the two
parties just loose around tough luck for
them right speaking it's the same time
never good for them but it might happen
see case we're a little bit of thinking
and modeling is involved what if both
listen okay now what if both listen
maybe the first thing you would try is
say peer silence okay let us not work so
if you define that the hue silence you
can actually just communicate totally
uncorrupted by communicating with the
silence and not silence ok so the right
thing to do here say if both parties
listen what's here is undetermined and
we want our protocol to work for
whatever they here so that's most
pessimistic that's most pessimistic
things that we could hope for if you can
algorithms for this it's going to be
great and this is the right model in the
sense that also it doesn't allow any
cheating and one way to see this is said
you know we can actually prove upper and
lower bounds an adversary can simulate
those fluid so it's it's almost the same
thing as saying the adversary gets to
choose whatever each party here's for
free it doesn't have to pay for it right
so it's a very it's it's the most
pessimistic model it's more or less the
only models that I know that doesn't
allow cheating and it also works very
nicely we didn't think about capacity in
the sense but does it works very nicely
so basically the whole idea is that I
give you see as the opportunity to call
it a tool adaptively decide but you
should not gain from the fact that you
miss to coordinate if you both listen if
you both speak at the same time you
should not gain an advantage from that
that's models addresses which is only
important if the messages of smooth user
an end of text symbol M so in all in all
of these in all of seeds and thinks we
declare the number of rounds a priori
and we run for fixed number of France
and then the protocol is affirmed that I
know that the message is you know so you
run for you declare an advance oh yeah
it's one simple sent in each round we
can now boast decide to either listen or
send a single symbol and each message is
assemble some single symbol yeah just
like before okay so it's a model clear
so if we both speak do we know that we
both spoke yeah he didn't listen you
have no idea what they are separated
also if both listened you cannot
distinguish whether the other person
actually talk to you and this was what
you heard or whether you just heard the
background noise yes see adversaries all
knows everything so it can okay so he
knows that they are going to speak at
the same time he knows that yeah so I
guess they say he gets to see this as I
speak at the same time and can decide to
interfere and do just to nothing or
listen at the same time in send aside
for tea what he goes okay so um so um
yeah I don't want to write so much so
just change this so see claim now is
it's falling so for every protocol so
two claims for every protocols that
exists on adaptive all right I'm which
similar to spy against any air raid of 2
/ 7 smaller than two or seven and on the
other hand the same thing simple
protocols the exchange protocol I claim
no protocol even adaptive one adaptive
non-adaptive no protocol whatever can
simulate the exchange for the call this
an air raid of exactly 207 that's a
technical statement so this is the
technical model this is a technical
technical statement is a statement clear
so that this statement so you describe
the model which is like pivot if you
allow the maximum flexibility so far
outer bounds it this is the most general
more than for Apple this is this is the
most pessimistic model right so if you
can if you can get an upper bounds and
that's if he can get a protocol then
that's generally nice yes exactly that's
for more advanced for me for so the
question is if this lower bound walks
also in some other models in as a model
so because because this is the most
pessimistic modern so it's great for
what about yeah maybe so on how would
you what kind of an exception so the
question is you know which other one
again so there are several other motives
but for example you can ask what happens
when they both listen if it's really
adversarial bit or maybe it's a some
other thing go yes a question is what
right so if it's silence you can cheat
if it's random you can cheat if it's I
mean basically more or less in generally
also if you want to say what to see what
I see rate right i mean this this thing
has a nice properties at each one of
communication we cannot exchange mores
in a single bit if for example allow a
silent symbol now suddenly you work over
trinary alphabet there are the one book
that will be too strong yeah i mean say
this i mean we sought long and hard
about it this I now after having sought
about it's a long list of reason why I
really want to say this a/c right model
and then also then we looked at capacity
which was something that we didn't have
in mind at Albany this sensor model
since this I think this is a sieve I'd
model to prove both upper bounds and
matching lower bounds so
so this is the height model like you're
saying that it's like a better model
than if you love and obedience yes yeah
like this when you know me the only days
of distributed computing that if you
allow silence for free then it allows
you really what about to cheat you can
really yeah if you allow silence but if
you don't allow silence if you in case
in silence it's a London beat or
something like that I mean you can yeah
let's see i mean this is this is a model
it's I think it's pretty clear that it's
a nice model we can talk about why it's
see best model or to talk about
different models but yeah so at least
this is a very natural formal model for
which we can prove things from both
sides okay okay so let me so I can't
believe so actually in the end I will
get you will see why how we actually
achieve this part at least more or less
it's not as easy to see why this is the
optimal protocol at least to give you a
little bit of a hint of white webs is
207 might creep up and how these things
look it will give you at least a
protocol that compute exchange when the
error rate is smaller than tourism okay
and that that already captures at least
a little bit and then we can talk
offline if you want to know more okay so
here's the protocols it achieves that
computes the exchange that simulates the
exchange protocol in an adaptive manner
with an error rate of two were seven
minus epsilon right so Z the protocol is
very simple we run in for example 700
rounds and I allow is slightly less than
200 years right 207 so I 199 errors
the protocol looks like this for 300
rounds alice is gonna send her bit then
for 300 rounds barb is gonna send hisp
it at this stage both of symbol try to
figure out if they already know what the
other party sent what's what see what
the other party's business when do I
know for sure what the other party spit
is and know so I received three hundred
bits but I know that that most 199
errors so that if Otto sees somebody
there are 200 there's bits which are the
same then i knows it exactly so if a
party receives 200 bits which are the
same since these cannot be wrong and
they know for sure that the other party
has the bits that i received 20 times
and in this case at this point it can
already decode games that they can
decode here what's it what should I so
there is going to be a hundred rounds
here which we basically going to decide
adaptively on in these 100 pounds if you
could decode in the beginning you don't
need to listen anymore right do you
already know everything that you need to
know so in this round if you can safely
the code you will send on the other hand
if after this first round you cannot
safely decode well then you better
listen some more now 199 error so if one
of them received 200 off the same thing
he can safely decoder claim its hundred
ninety nine errors at least one party
will safely decode well in order for one
party not to safely decodes the
adversary needs to spend at least one
hundred and one error son you cannot
spend 101 errors on both parties doesn't
happen so one of the parties will safely
decode as a both of them safely decode
sigil boast hark at the end nobody will
listen it doesn't matter they already
safely decoded otherwise one part
safely because that party will speak the
other party they'll listen in total the
other party will have received four
hundred times and listen four hundred
times at most 199 out of those four
hundred times are corrupted so if you
could just go over the majority you good
questions
now this is a sea optimal protocol to
see that really this is the optimal
protocol it's a little bit more
complicated and then I won't tell you
now why but at least you got a spurt
what sourcing okay cool so let's yes 20
arrows it will just put 100 GM you fool
the majority yeah oh yeah so it will
break it and it will just put basically
we'll put know it will put all airs on
one side right one party listens at most
four hundred times 200 offs or other
source will be corrupted you don't know
which 200 ones yeah so since I see wanna
see epsilon right so this 2 / 7 this is
exactly 207 s2000 should break and it
will break order and you want to see you
want to simulate it in the way that your
bus against almost 27 there so the
original protocol there's no noise in
the virtual protocol right being an
oyster setting so there's never a reason
for you to speak at the same time in the
noisiest setting so without loss of
generality the original protocol is
there's no non-adaptive adapted same
okay so in this particular case you only
needed to one round of adaptively
changing the schedule of speaking yeah I
mean 100 rounds but I mean there's
either blocks of 400 yes yep yep so in
general how many times you need to sort
of also in general it's one yeah so we
have CZ protocols at x i mean i can give
you the description off of the two of
seven protocol hopefully okay cool so
let's switch let's switch
topics so so this is roughly what I have
to say about 14 so yes one force is see
best air rates at one can achieve for
the standard model which is non-adaptive
but if you go to you know very natural
adaptive model you can beat one over for
you can achieve 2 / 7 207 is tight okay
now now we know what to maximum error
rate is so two things that I want to
still tell you is how to achieve things
efficiently computational efficiency and
ideally we also want to achieve things
computationally efficient and having the
optimal error right alright so in
contrast to the things that are on the
board right now we want some best thing
here and the best thing here okay and
turns out see the only way I know how to
do things and there's a key concept in
in both achieving 2 / 7 and in getting
things adaptive s or in getting things
computationally efficient while
preserving optimal error rate is 200
verlis decoding okay so good fraction of
you probably will have will know what
list according is from error correcting
codes it's it's kind of a funny funny
concept at least in the beginning if you
see it for the first time you go
probably oh maybe think it's a kind of
it's a neat little little problem
variation of little youth couldn't you
couldn't be more wrong so list according
for for air correcting codes is just
falling usually I say Alice wants to
know exactly a pop wants to know exactly
what what else at now least according
said you don't need to uniquely decode
whatever sent it's good enough to
generate a list of a constant number of
things let's say a hundred different
strengths that and one of them needs to
be correct and in error correcting codes
we know that the distances that he can
achieve this is decoding versus the
distances that you can achieve this
this unique decoding is roughly a factor
of two apart right and the same will
happen here so if we can tolerate in a
standard model one over for this unique
decoding you will be able to tolerate
one half this list according and this
will be the key to to everything that
said follows so Alice Bob compute list
size constant containing the correct
outcome
and if you think of this binary tree at
the end basically each outcome
corresponds to a leaf so I'm just going
to output kind of constant number of
leaves one of them should be the correct
one it's a definition of list
accordingly now let me try to give you
at least so why do we care about list
according right I mean what does list
according have to do this this unique
decoding which arguably we might care
more about let me try to give you at
least one simple example where a problem
that's purely about unique decoding
really has less decoding hidden in it
okay so let's look at the at a setting
let's call it one way one way one sided
unique decoding we only want one one
pre-announce party to decode uniquely so
if Alice we have pop so you go back and
forth there's going to be a bunch of
errors in here and in the end we want
Alice to know exactly what see original
outcome boss and Bob my you know Bob
might not what might could be one could
be to the outcome could be three you
know for who knows right this is a
question purely about unique decoding I
think it's also an interesting case or
web-based is an interesting question
Cinco for example is a is a program B is
the database a is going to make adaptive
cruise to the database and the queer is
going to come back with some noise in
the end what we really want to guarantee
the program ran correctly all right the
program should figure out what the
original thing was without notes does
the database need to know what question
we originally asked no not really we
don't care right or you you know your
student comes to you and wants to solve
a problem and your sis you know this big
database who knows everything
so the students going to ask you a
question is this true is that true is
this to us a true you could give him
answers so you only think that's
important you know you might
misunderstand each other on the way the
only thing that's important is that it's
a student in the end it's all the right
answers do you need to know what he
proved not really right it's okay all
right so this is purely about unique
decoding I claims it if Alice can
uniquely decode intuitively Bob better
be able to list a code line circuit my
sister case well if Bob in the end has
no clue what Alice wanted to compute
well obviously huge database it can go
knee if give very limited answers if in
the very end he has no clue what L is
merely was aiming it how could it
possibly given the right answers there
too many options here then equal if not
possibly give them the answers so even
to be really just asking about unique
decoding of Alice I claims it what we
really need to solve in between it's
very least is Bob should be able to in
the end figure out at least a reasonably
small list of things that I just wanted
to compute otherwise it cannot get the
right answers and so the way it is the
way all of these things are going to
work in the end you're going to start so
this is the overall this is the overall
game plan you're going to start with an
inefficient list decoder
we're going to have one step which
boosts the computational efficiency of
this list decoder there's less decoder
boosting from the machine learning
boosting just computational efficiency
and once you have an efficient mystic
order we're gonna have basically one
reduction or a bunch of very similar
reductions which given a list Accord to
actually construct unique decoders so
this is ISA reductions am i doing my
time so when we have to stop 1045 so I
have like half an hourish okay cool um
so everything every saw is the only way
a [ __ ] and no to achieve one force
efficiently or two over seven
efficiently is so cool as this art start
vasilis decoder boost its efficiency and
then reduce it to eat according okay so
i will try to in the last 30 minutes
give you kind of flavor or almost
complete descriptions of these two
thanks let's see if he if you make it in
time okay let's start this boosting ok
so the boosting is a part which
introduces efficiency so boosting what
we want is
we have a list decoders that tolerates
some Delta fraction of errors it's not
necessarily efficient or that's actually
say we only need it for us I mean the
whole idea is to only run the list
accord on very small protocols and then
assemble it many of these executions to
a bigger protocol because you only need
to run it on a small protocol even if
you brute force over the smallest things
it's going to be much more efficient
right and be furthermore going to
recurse this whole thing so we can
instead of actually brute forcing over
the smallest thing we chained can just
reduce it to something even smaller
until they get constant size or just
logarithmic sighs I meet brute force
okay so what we want is supposed at a
half a list decoder that one's for a log
squared some constant times locks read
many rounds I want to get a list decoder
which basically achieves the more or
less the same error tolerate the same
error rate has similar efficiency up to
a constant similar list signs up to a
constant but it works for in for an N
one particle clear what we want so how
are we going to do this well basically
we try to compute this whole thing's
it's a complete ass in blocks of size
log squared and going to protect each of
these things right so we run in in n
over log squared n times the constant so
over epsilon many iterations you get a
little thin and yes
I will try haha much better and yeah so
we run in n over log squared and we have
so many iterations and in each of these
iterations we want to kind of append
want to search down another log n log
squared log squared n of the correct
path that's that's a hope so in
particular what we do is a following so
each of these iterations we bands
following protocol we first look at all
prior all prior prior blocks so yeah the
code actually oh all right blocks and
then based on this decoding we try to
interactively find a good place to
continue our conversation find a good
starting point
and once we have the starting point we
actually for log squared and rounds
you're just going to have the
conversation so if you if you think of
this big tree we have already had some
conversation so it gives us some gas of
V as the right path might be we find a
good guess i will makes us more precise
in in a bit but once you have the
starting point we will continue for
continued for log squared n blocks
Iran's and of course we don't want to do
this in the clear right so this in total
this is hopefully going to be quick this
is only log squared and long we want to
protect this whole thing and we're going
to use the Delta lista coders that we
assumes that we have and protect this
whole thing here with a delta lista
corner and then be going to iterate it
says you know this often so we again run
the next block in which we decode find a
good point and starting point
I didn't use the conversation and so on
right we do this in over epsilon locks
quite enough now see parts that we kind
of need to be more precise as this part
right I mean what do I mean mr. coat I
mean the coating is actually pretty
clear but once we have decoded how do we
find a good starting point right so sees
the list decoders right so at some point
down here I can look at what happened in
these conversations and I can decode
some right what will happen when I
decodes them each of the parties will
generate a list of possible outcomes
what is an outcome here an outcome is a
starting point in the continuation of
the path so we get for each of these
things here we get a constant number
let's say a hundred combinations of
starting point and continuation starting
point and continuation 100 of source and
there's going to be like water in
roughly order n many of souls if you
deep down say we have all of these six
now one of these continuations and wanna
see starting points is the correct one
if the error in this block was small as
in Delta if the error was large is in
Delta we have no guarantee whatsoever
everything could be completely made up
so basically if you take all if we
decode all of the blocks that we have 24
in the right down starting points
country in the oceans if you just look
at what versi edges what will my edges
which were used in these paths these are
good candidates for useful edges right
hopefully some of these blocks were
actually correct then the use four edges
our are among the set so what the
parties are going to do is they look at
all the edges involved in all these
paths right so it gives us or take all
edges so Alice takes all a edges
it's getting small I'm sorry takes all
all the edges and of the prior blocks
and I claim that this forms a tree and
the size of this tree is at most linear
really yes yes that's right so Oh
protocol something like this now Ellis
let's try to you some different colors
so Ellis knows the answer to the first
question right this one was it's Alice
knows big blend that you later so your
list decoding will give you a small set
of leaves it not of leave so I did will
give you every time it gives you a
starting point and i'll log log squared
along paths that continues to its mm-hmm
and how do you propose to repeatedly
useless decoding on this tree so each
user's plot will give you a hundred
starting points which are some way in
the tree and a pass from this point
onwards which is log squared n one look
at all of C edges all of your edges
which are on this path for all paths and
all times this is a random set of random
set of edges it's a subset of your edges
and right so you take set set of edges
and hopefully a bunch of good edges
which are actually on the correct path
are among them
very first application of this blog Oh
first application finding us there's
nothing to decode starting the good
starting point is the beginning it's a
route it's just a very good and you can
you just run the first login runs of
Noel's at ya so you get a bunch of
number of paths you include all of the
edges how many of those edges are there
100 times log squared now given these as
these edges form a tree right i mean
basically they're just like simple
passes from the root now you take this
tree and you find it both of C Part II
have a tree and they try to find a good
starting point I haven't told you how
they find a good starting point but
basically both parties when ZD codes
they get a tree it's a three of
polynomial size consisting only of Syria
edges it's a good thing is if she takes
intersection of these three there's only
one path and we want to find the deepest
leaf on this path so there's a problem
that we trying to do here is something
like three intersection the promise
problem I give you a bunch of edges I
give you a bunch of edges the
intersection of them has exactly one
unique path find it and find it quickly
right yeah so if you decode you get a
tree and finding a good starting point
is really doing tree intersection does
it make sense so far so if he can solve
three intersection in that's a log
squared n runs you would be very happy
first round we just takes a rude as a
starting point we compute the next Lok
thread and rounds we protected by a
lista corner now in the next round we
look at the outcome of this listing
Hodor this basically gives us a hundred
a hundred passes both parties get 100
passes which are consistent with the
edges and in total you have like a
hundred log squared n edges the
intersection as a union of these edges
has to exactly one unique pass which
might be the empty pass if this was too
much corrupted it will be the correct
pass if this was not clear if the errors
in here were very less you make that any
passes like but let engage party
contestame go Jesus forever other causes
of these edges yeah so the edge City
keep our only your edges so every so
every VHS that you keep a consistent
with what you have since if it takes a
union of some that can only be it needs
to be consistent with you and visa is
only one pass we want to find the
deepest link of this past this is where
we want to continue okay and yeah so the
street intersections proms problem it's
not hard to solve if we wanted with high
probability in a randomized manner we
just do binary search in hash okay so
how exactly do we do this let's generate
some log n long independent independent
randomness LSN set one over now we have
some shared randomness use that
randomness to hash all each of these
edges has an app to order in long
description but they only polynomially
many of them right so let's take this
order n long description of any edge
and hash it into a log and bit string
and because we use a random hash this
high probabilities that name will be
unique among the order in edges that
they are because it will basically be a
random a random log and bit string all
right so it's high probability we have a
short description unique description for
every edge on on your side these
renovations have interrupted and and no
in the sand said this is what's
happening inside here alright so we
writing in so he dividing a protocol in
which we assume there is no noise and
then we protect this protocol with
holistic order so here we can assume
that there is no noise and then if the
total noise in here what smaller than
this then one of the outcomes will be
the correct no noise outcome yeah so
essentially we r we really want to solve
this with no noise so once I have seized
unique description of the edges are just
two binary search so in particular Alice
takes her tree so it's going to be one
edge which if I remove it see two
subtrees both of them are constants I
smaller let's test whether this edge is
on the path well I sense the name over
an ass pop hey do you have an edge that
matches this description do you have
this edge if he also has this edge then
it's on the path if it's on the past we
only need to search in the subtree right
we discarded everything that was not in
the sub tree which was at least some
constant fraction on the other hand if
it's not on his path I don't need to
search in the subtree so Alice discards
the whole sub tree so this one exchange
of login of a log and bit identifier she
cuts down her tree by half she does this
logarithmically often for total
communication of logs quit and we found
the deepest point in the tree with high
probability
now see searching part is log squared
long's this is log squared long so in
total is still only locks weird long and
we can protect the pessimistic order so
this is this is a protocol I guess as
the only things that I need to say how
do we decode in the end what is what we
output right what the output is in the
end we decode all the aussies list since
gives us again at three of at least of
at most polynomial size like n over
epsilon many edges any leaves of that
any leaves of said power of said tree I
will output
can you repeat what the hashes are for
the tree intersection problem um what's
the hashes are so basically I just take
a random hash function so the property
for the hash function I want is that if
I have pulley normally many things like
order n many edges which I have a long
description I use the same random string
to hash souls the same scene to hash
souls into like log and bit identifiers
and what I want is if there are
different edges and with high
probability they will have different
names so one way to view is the hash
just makes it like a protocol with a
much smaller tree and then you just do
the naive protocol on the street I'm on
a much smaller tree edges so that you
just get a small tree yes the
description off the edges is small now
instead of kind of describing an edge by
the whole path to it right which can be
order n long I want to give it a short
nickname right such that you and I know
which H we are talking about I can't so
you can view the entire problem that
you're trying to solve here is tree
intersection right on a big universe the
entire communication problem is a tree
intersection problem yes we just wants
this promise problem smaller space and
then somehow solving a juicing Nash
that's what the list according is that
is an accurate description of who is
small so I'm not sure what you mean with
you reduce it to a smaller tree if you
start before the party start
communicating they all have their sets
of edges but they're trying to compute
the tree intersection yes but and now we
now we have here we have trees that are
smaller and we can we can do this
efficiently
so let's let's try to finish this up so
why is this so why advices kind of quick
intuition why is this correct so
definitely it's fast right why is it
correct two things we need to prove the
correct parts will be included in the
list right my is the case well in order
for in order for block to get corrupted
to not make lock and progress on the
correct path log squared progress on the
correct path it needs to be at least a
delta fraction of errors but the total
area rate is an epsilon smaller so at
least kind of an epsilon fraction of
everything here is well go through will
we have less than Delta Delta fraction
of Earth's right since we're running for
an epsilon number of times more often it
really means that in this epsilon
fraction of times we will be able to go
all the way to the leaf why don't we
output too many things well essentially
it's a number of edges the behalf is
still you know linear and over epsilon
and if you output all the leaves that
kind of go go deep enough we there can't
be too many leaves at the output this
was the list size will still be a
constant it will be in one of epson
factor larger but okay so constant
so the total number of edges is small
right it's a total number of edges in
all the list is at most kind of a
hundred times in over epsilon so you're
gonna take the original protocol and
just an every leaf append kind of a
little bit of a path and and then you
only look at leaves it kind of follows
this path now now you can only have a
constant number of I mean now we can
only have yeah cause number fees okay
yeah so I still want to give you a
little bit of a hint how we do the
second part how we do this reduction so
unless it's the intuition clear protocol
roughly clear oh okay so last little
part if you have an efficient district
holder how do we get a unique decoder
okay and
essentially so okay so what is the
formal statements for my statements is
if we have one force minus epsilon list
decoder then we get a one force minus 2
epsilon unique decoder that's the first
thing and it's what's interesting about
it is that we really don't even need an
optimal istic order to get to gets us I
so optimistic order would tolerate one
half here in a holistic order of this
one force is good enough and essentially
we get this unique decoding for free
non-adaptive right as the other things
basically the same reduction just proof
is a little bit more complicated if we
get a one-half an optimal istic order 1
minus epsilon list decoder then we can
also get a 2 / 7 minus 2 epsilon
adaptive unique decoder when we can for
example also get a 1 over 3 minus 2
epsilon one-sided
decoder 131 sir dissolves is the optimal
area right here okay so basic and these
are black box reduction I just need to
know that they exist this as this list
accord and if it's efficient then also
this reduction will be efficient oh I'm
so how does this how does this reduction
work so let's focus on this case right
how do I if I have a one-quarter list
decoder how can I actually saw it outs
right list so maybe the first thing that
one could try is well let's one first
one the list decoder this gives Bop A
List and Alice a list and Barb a
different list and if the error rate
here is smaller than a quarter so in the
correct thing is among it now if you
have these lists again this is only a
kind of a linear number of edges the
correct ones are hopefully among it so
if I just take those edges and send them
over using an error correcting code I
would be great so use an error
correcting code Alice sends looks at all
the a edges in l and send so it's over
to Bob and Bob takes an error correcting
code takes all the B edges in L prime
wraps them into an error correcting code
and sensors over if the error rate here
was smallest in a quarter these lists
includes the correct edges if these air
creating courts can have a distance of
one half if the air wait in here is also
smaller than a quarter then these air
cracking codes will be at most one half
corrupted and these error correct I can
you near I can decode sees a HSN CSP
edges now if if I can do this and I just
intersection with my thing and I gets a
correct pass right so this attempt will
work if the error rate in here is that
most of water and the air
of years at most a quarter and the first
week less decoding and then we pick up
the right thing by sending are using
error correcting codes why does this not
quite work yet yeah so the adversary can
likes this makes up half of the
protocols this makes up half of the
protocol there's no guarantees that the
adversary nicely distributes here's one
quarter here one quarter here right it
might decide to completely kill only the
first parts and it can crop this with
one half and it can kill this or it can
crop this with one half and kill one of
these error correcting codes for example
completely so you still want to kind of
do this but ideally would like to run
them at the same time the problem is
running them at the same time is we
can't really send the error-correcting
codes if you don't have seized if you
don't have seized lists it so we kind of
so how did get around says find a
particle looks almost like this just be
repeated a bunch of times so in the
beginning we run the list decoder and we
get a list one and a list 1 prime for
Bob then we run this list decoder again
and shameless Dakota we get another two
and then ultra prime but now in addition
to running this list coder at the same
time I will also send error correcting
codes for a edges of l1a1 and and B
edges of l2 l1 prime
oh one prime right at this point I have
some I sent them over I repeat this a
bunch of times 1 over epsilon so this is
n rounds and I in total around this kind
of 1 over epsilon often and inside this
just writes a third round we again run a
list decoder we get a third list this on
each side and now we don't just send a
one but we send all the edges that are
in l1 or l2 these error correcting codes
are inside the mystical and know these
basically we use a large alphabet on one
part of the alphabet we're on the list
accord on then we append kind of CZ i
mean this is a number of in symbols
right the length of this is kind of one
string a constant number of strings of
length n you might put this into an
error correcting codes which is like
order and symbols and we just kind of
send a symbol that corresponds fizzle
istic holder and we you know cross
product it is a symbol off feat justin
tuples alright so that's kind of how we
run them at the same time it will blow
up our alphabet but in double our author
I mean doubles bit size of our alphabet
but you know for now we don't care so
here we send CA edges of l1 and l2 now
in order for the adversary to so how do
we decode in the end we basically just
be only look at sea as the
error-correcting codes we look at what
passes what f sets do we get each of
these air cracking codes we decode is
the closest code word it corresponds to
some edge set of CR as a party we look
intersected with outset what end point
does it correspond to and we essentially
take some kind of majority so we do soft
decoding if if you're something that's
very far away from something they
sounded very little confidence if it's
exactly kind of
points and you assign it a lot of
confidence when you just kind of look at
the overall confidence and you pick outs
one pass so it has the highest
confidence now for the adversary to kill
this it needs to corrupt the list
decoders so once it doesn't corrupt one
of these blocks sufficiently enough from
there on the right edges will be
included in all the error-correcting
codes thereafter so essentially for the
adversary to kill this it needs to kill
all the arrow crack are all the listed
quarters up to some point so for one
round it's good because you know we
didn't didn't have a chance to transfer
it over but except for this one round it
needs to quote kill all the
error-correcting codes hereafter
otherwise we get the rising over that's
the intuition and then you just do you
just you and all these so this is this
is how this works and all these things
here work essentially the same thing so
instead of having kind of says this
decoding party basically for the 247 we
have in protocols it roughly runs three
runs this for 3 3 1 over epsilon mini
bounds ss6 10 reps in many rounds and
then we have kind of one round in which
one party should be able to decode and
just send error correcting codes list
according works the same way kind of we
mirror what we do for the exchange
protocol and we put in these lists
according things and that's that's a
reduction and then proving that it works
this a little bit more tricky but i
think the intuition should be clear now
I haven't shown you how to actually get
a list accord with one half right so
that's a big piece that's missing so
klim is going to talk about that on
Thursday one interesting thing to note
is that if he so if we if we want to get
for example 2 / 7 we need claims result
right what we're going to do we take
glimpse result the boosted in efficiency
and then we we want this reduction we
need a really good list decoder
interesting was one over four result
you already know how to do it why we
have an inefficient lista Corder with
air wait 1 / 4 namely what our new
papers it's a really good list accorded
has list size 1 it's still a list a
quarter right so interprets brother
Monroe is an inefficient listing holder
boost its efficiency using the tree
intersection part and then applies this
reduction and you get a 1 / 4 1 minus 4
1 / 4 unique decoder which is
computationally efficient let me finish
up with kind of some open questions so
one good open question is deterministic
particles so all of these protocols are
efficient but there's a randomized can
we get can we get something that's
efficient indeterministic interestingly
actually these protocols are non uniform
you can make some non uniform
deterministic so instead of kind of
making it our time our time and squared
you can make it d times n square / pony
that's halfway there no because even if
I give you a tree code how are you going
to decode it so even make ya hear these
are really exponential time this is not
p / body yeah so here we get something
that's so if I think really hard if I
run my supercomputer can compute a
really short circuit which computes what
I want which is deterministic I still
need to really search very hard to find
it but but then the circuit will be
small right that's not true for anything
that's not true for any things that we
know how to do these three cuts but yeah
so non-uniform deterministic we don't
know how to do all of this assumes that
we operate over large symbols what if
you want binary protocols it's
everything that you can do here you can
do let's say binary protocols for the
loss of a factor of two just using error
correcting codes is really easy so we
can for exam
get a 1 over 8 unique decoder for the
standard model the question is is that
optimal and we don't know you can prove
that you can do better than 1 over 6 but
we're between 16 and over ed I write
down slides I don't know this if the Z
the proofs that works kind of Sierra
correct improve the 4z the lower bound
doesn't doesn't hold because we have
feedback that's another big question
then well the obvious as a big question
is right but we're going to talk about
this tomorrow and yeah things that's
basically it I'm sorry in the end
obviously it went a little bit faster